Today we have another incredible lesson for
you with Harry Potter! By the way in case
you're new here did you know that every
week we make lessons just like this one
to help you learn fast native english without
getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles! Take Bruna from Brazil for
instance she says that her English has improved a
lot and that we make really fun and interesting
classes! So if you want to learn in this way
join our community of over 4 million
learners by hitting that subscribe
button and the bell down below so that
you don't miss any of our new lessons!
To learn more about the Harry Potter Houses
and see in which House you'd best fit in run
over to our Instagram after this lesson to
check out the posts we've made for you there.
How would you like to develop confidence in your
speaking whilst having real-life conversations at
the touch of a button! When connecting with
other learners from all around the world!
Sounds like a dream right well now with the
RealLife App we've made it a reality! You
can download the app for free and improve your
listening and speaking whenever and wherever you
want. Just click the link in the description
down below or you can simply search for the
RealLife English App in the Google Play or
Apple App Store. Now download it now and
let us guide you beyond the classroom to live
and learn and speak English in the real world.